Arne Mellie needs to be in Silicon
Valley because they're one of the top
universities for computing and software
and hardware and robotics and AI and
this is the place where businesses are
started based on those technologies
Carnegie Mellon has a major reputation
in systems building and computer science
and software engineering and that's the
key business of the valley and the
companies in the area are very
forward-looking they're looking toward
the research community for the next
innovation that kind of
cross-fertilization between academia and
industry this is just a fantastic place
to do that now in all of our programs we
try to blend business communications
teamwork and technical so that people
can be leaders in their part of the
industry students come out with the
threat to deal with people with
technology and the business and also
with depth they learn the skills and the
techniques and understanding of how the
field is evolving we have a model of
intense engagement where faculty would
play roles and act as mentors and
students have to work on authentic
problems together learning by doing is a
proven technique for getting students to
understand material at a deeper level
they get practice in the actual skills
of the domain as well as coming up with
the concepts and the methodologies that
they can take back to their organization
people actually learn best you know when
they're taught in the context of doing
meaningful authentic work the kind of
work to which they're going to apply the
things they learn after they've learned
them being able to access this learn by
doing in kind of a sandbox environment
is something that I don't think any
other program at any other school offers
and it's an experience that every
software engineer should definitely have
in
we're another and I think that's the way
that Carnegie Mellon Silicon Valley
delivers on that experience it is
something that you wouldn't get at any
other program at any other school the
great thing about the Carnegie Mellon
program is that you can take the
learnings that you have here and apply
them at your job immediately and
Carnegie Mellon gives you the skills to
be able to do that whether it's having
the confidence and the knowledge to
participate as an industry player or
whether it's to innovate and start
something new there's very strong
technical schools in in Stanford and
also in Berkeley out here but they don't
have the same emphasis on
entrepreneurship and what does it take
to bring technology to market Carnegie
Mellon has a great reputation of
teaching you know world-class engineers
now they have the opportunity to not
only learn you know how to be a great
engineer but also to do it here in in
the heart of Silicon Valley and I think
that's a sort of a double benefit
you